before we get going today i want to
begin with a quick reminder that daily
wire memberships are 50 off right now
this is the last day of the deal you
don't want to miss out on this
opportunity
and uh and i'll be honest with you we
need your support we need your help we
we aren't just making
content at the daily wire we're fighting
and we need you to join us in the fight
we're going up against the by the
administration we're turning the tide in
elections we're uncovering major
scandals we're doing all of that with
the help of our subscribers who are very
much a part of the team
and a part of the special thing that
we're building here at the daily wire
and that's why i'm calling on all of my
sweet babies to become daily wire
members also we're creating culture you
know we don't want to just comment on
culture we want to create it
and we are but again we can't do that
without you and as far as creating
culture goes i can tell you that i've
been working on two projects the first
i'll announce tonight on tucker carlson
it's a book that i've been writing for
many months um i've been put my i've put
my heart and soul into it
and i'm really excited to tell you about
it on tucker's show tonight it is i
believe i think it's my magnum opus
really the second project will be
revealed within the next few months i
can't tell you anything about it
except that i'm literally traveling
across the world for it and it's
something that will make it'll make a
lot of people very angry the book i'll
announce tonight will also make a lot of
people very angry but more importantly i
think both will have an impact on the
culture and there these are the kinds of
things we're only able to do
with your support it's an exciting time
the daily wire we've got lots of things
in the works that you aren't expecting
and that will take you by surprise and
if you want to be a part of all that go
to daily wire use code dw50 get your 50
discount today and again make sure to
tune in to tucker carlson tonight